[Music]
[Applause]
oh look who's joining us it's the Miami
Heat Insider of course Dan Le batard
joins us the other day the uh mouthpiece
for the Heat and he said the Dame
Lillard was coming to Miami he he will
be this season he's just not going to
stay there Dan so uh how's my round
today
all right uh let me begin this I began
the last one by professing publicly
loudly uh borderline romantically my
love and respect for you I'm going to
start differently this time and I'm
going to tell your worldwide audience
that you are a dirty trickster that I
now uh I resent deeply and I will
explain myself in just a second I know
it's a short segment here but for 20
years basically uh Dan Patrick maybe not
20 but 15 years he calls me when in a
dolphin offensive line coach does
cocaine off of his desk and sends a
romantic uh video to an exotic worker in
Las Vegas or some such Miami Calamity to
talk about the Dolphins usually only
something they've done wrong I go and I
make a bunch of people at ESPN mad by
never asking permission to go on your
show and just doing it anyway and the
Dolphins are finally 3-0
they finally have an exciting team we
have something positive to talk about so
Dan Patrick calls me and tricks me into
talking about the Dolphins for a while
and then at the end what does he do he
asks the question that makes me publicly
a larger fool more wrong than I've ever
been about anything
in front of a worldwide
Intergalactic audience uh the morale is
is well I was just going to curse the
morale is terrible but it's it is Pat
Riley keeps swinging and missing he got
three whales in 2010 and now Miami
thinks every time there is a player
available Pat Riley should correct the
mistake of Lillard when not wanting to
come here by now getting Luca and
Anthony Edwards for uh yertz event that
he should now just get him Beed and
everybody and they're mad because uh it
looks like everyone that competes with
the heat in that conference where they
finishes the eighth seed last year uh
those competitors have gotten better in
Miami has not uh because it's not just
merely that Portland sent Damien Lillard
not to Miami but they sent him to a team
that I thought was better than Miami
before they got Damian Lillard
foreign
you didn't have to guarantee that Dame
was going to Miami Dan
hearing an actual heat mouthpiece as I
did so I was not expecting for people to
say this was a journalistic objective
guarantee I was you could barely
understand me I was muffling it through
an actual Miami Heat mouthpiece
you used to be a journalist
now you're an Entertainer
you're an Entertainer
I am a sanctimonious the worst kind of
the worst the worst kind of Entertainer
a sanctimonious self-important
Entertainer who gets things profoundly
wrong in a way that Echo from sea to
shining scene that should be the name of
your show it's a little wordy but that
should be the name of your show from now
on because if because of
my tombstone
well you always have the Dolphins this
season Dan
oh I hope too it doesn't get injured
just based on you and me talking
uh my best to uh the uh the crew there
and Stu gotz and and thank you and I
hope you have a wonderful weekend Dan
International shame you don't care how
my weekend is that's Dan Le batard
show with stew guy International very
funny
you're talking International shame yeah
then I'm sorry about that
uh he's a good sport he's a good sport